of everyone he goes do you know that
Tyra Banks invented America's Next Top
Model and I said do you think I turned
gay yesterday
they were dying did you talk with Tyler
at all oh yeah I saw her in the lobby
and I just walked by her I go Tyra and
she like looked up and I was like we're
on the show tomorrow see ya she's like
okay what a professional she showed up
on time she looked great she was nice to
everybody she memorized all her lines
like she was easy to work with she took
pictures of everybody like then
afterwards she came up to us in the
hotel lobby and she was like oh my God I
just went to a five guys and they had
the best milkshakes and we're like it's
Tyra Banks talking to me about
milkshakes right now this is a fever
dream